Okay, Michael, so that was a great conversation, what have we learned?
>> Alright, well we talked about ensemble learning
which was the idea of instead of just
learning one thing, if it's good to learn
once, it's even better to learn multiple times,
>> In multiple ways.
>> The simple version that we concentrated on first was
this notion of bagging. Where what we did is instead
of just learning on the whole data set, we would
sub-sample bunch of examples from the training set, different ways,
and train up different classifiers or different learners on each
of those and then merge them together with the average.
>> Okay, so if I can summarize
that, we learned that ensembles are good. [LAUGH]
>> We learned that even simple ensembles like bagging are good.
>> We talked about the fact that by using this kind
of ensemble approach, you can take simple learners or simple classifiers and
merge them together and get more complicated classifiers.
>> Mm, yeah, so we can take. We
can. Combining simple gives you complex. Anything else?
>> And we talked about the idea of boosting where you
can Oh, maybe this is why it's called boosting. You can take
something that has possibly very high error but always less than
a half, and turn it into something that has very low error.
>> So we learned that boosting is really good.
And, we talked a little bit about why, that's
good. By the way, there's a whole bunch of
other details here too, right? Boosting also has the
advan, as does bagging Not only has these little
properties you've talked about before, but it tends to be
very fast. It's agnostic to the learner. As you
noticed, that in no time, did we say, try
to take advantage of what the actual learner was
doing. Just that it was, in fact, a weak learner.
>> Hm.
>> So I think that's important. It's agnostic.
>> Meaning you can plug in any learner you want?
>> Yeah. So long as it's a weak learner. So there's something
we learned about. We learned about weak learners that we defined with that
meant. And, we also talked about ,um, what error really, really means.
With respect to some kind of underlying distribution. What do you think Michael?
>> That seems like useful stuff.
>> These are useful stuff to me. I'm going to throw one more
thing at you, Michael, before I let you go. Okay, you ready?
>> Yep.
>> Here's a simple fact. About boosting that
turns out in practice. You know our
favorite little over-fitting example. Do you know
how over-fitting works? You have a training
line that tends to get better, and better,
and better. Maybe even going down to zero error. But then you have test
error Which gets better and better and at some point it starts to get worse.
>> Mm.
>> And at that point you have over fitting and I think,
Michael, you asserted it at some point or maybe I asserted that
,you always have to worry about over fitting. Over fitting is
just the kind of fact of life. You got to come
up with ways to deal with it or sort of over
believing your data. Well, what if I told you that in practice
When you run boosting, even as you run it over time
so that your training error keeps getting better and better and
better and better, it also turns out that your testing error
keeps getting better and better and better and better and better and
better and better.
>> That seems too good to be true.
>> It does seem too good to be true. It turns out it's
not too good to be true. And I have an explanation for it.
>> Tell me.
>> Not until next time.
>> alright, see you then.
>> See you then. Bye.